okay
that said looked bad
down five percent but yeah past six
months up another 15 so guys I would get
in now that's and that is that is
financial advice
[Laughter]
sorry not Financial advice yes it is
financial advice it is exactly what to
do with your money Cody's word's not
mine JK crazy we talked about crypto for
like six years yeah
it's been an underlying theme the entire
history of our podcast and it's back to
where it was and it still is going to be
is what I'm saying yep it's a scam yeah
who would have thought
who would have thought that this whole
time it was like
cryptos like we haven't had a cool I've
probably already said this but it's like
we've had a cool technological New Wave
since the iPhone crypto might be that
thing and we're waiting and they're like
here's some pictures of apes
that costs a million dollars and we're
like this is kind of weird yeah it
doesn't really seem like but okay
what else like well some pictures of
some punks
and some coins named after buttholes and
stuff like there's Joe Biden saying the
n-word
wait what
are you talking about AI yeah yeah yeah
that's the new yeah actual one yeah yeah
you know all the money guys are like
whoa whoa yeah all the crypto guys are
like whoa now this is what I'm talking
about
bro yeah wait what there's Joe Biden
yeah you haven't seen that I mean I saw
an AI clip like a deep fake of him but I
don't know if it was that one dude
they're they're all like
dude overnight the Deep fakes oh my God
you see the one of Patrick Mahomes as
Kenny Powers no dude can you search that
Luke's as him I mean it is like you know
he like went on Jimmy Kimmel or whatever
and he was like Yeah The Chain Smokers
and the and that's all the music you
need right there smokers and DJ Khalid
that's all the music you need right
there
someone like deep faked him as Kenny
Powers in it you can't tell it's uncanny
[Applause]
where do you guys go do you congregate
party the whole deal yeah I know so we
started off they actually do a nice uh
party for us at the hotel The
Chainsmokers came through DJ Khaled came
through
um you can't beat that man that's every
genre of music you need right there and
then uh we had a little after party
after that as well and you just get the
guys together man and you just
celebrating they actually got the the
plane ride home and then I get one day
off to get my rest and then parade on
Wednesday Chiefs Kingdom I'll I'm I'm
ready to see you there how crazy is that
yeah
it's it's like you can't tell anymore
pretty well this is the um
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
isn't just any lackluster cause we are
making aware
Trump me and Joe have thought about it
recently and I think we're ready to join
your Minecraft realm sorry about
yesterday
was so [__] fun yesterday bro Trump
you really missed out yeah yeah whatever
guys I'm gonna reset the realm and we
can all start from fresh cool with you
gang say less Drilla he sounds Jizzy
young team stop with these gay ass names
bruh also Joe wake your sleepy ass up
this time and download the right [__]
game God damn it shut the [__] up you
literally look like a hairy [__]
orange what regardless I knew I
downloaded the wrong game last time bro
so why the [__] did your rotting ass not
say anything about not wanting to play
Minecraft first of all Pixel Gun 3D is
goated as [__]
[Laughter]
the Biden one's the only one that sounds
real yeah yeah the other ones yeah coded
as [__]
this is a bunch of Joe Biden just being
like I'm smoking that Necromancer Kush
this [__] will put you flat on your it's
so stupid you want to know some scary
[__] though yeah go go click that second
link so this is a tweet from someone
some
some dude that's in on what's you know
the bleeding edge of AI or whatever
there was a paper written somewhere
uh in Osaka
so basically they were able to
they did an MRI they trained a language
model so like an AI model on brain waves
and like basically they would show
people images
they would take whatever brain waves
were generated they would train an AI on
those brain waves and then later they
showed people
images like that weren't related to like
weren't the same as the other images
people just looked at the images they
thought about the images and the AI
model recreated what they were thinking
literally read the person's mind
how [__] scary is that
Minority Report baby it's here
I mean that is that not the
did you just think about killing someone
you're going to jail
that's wild
yep how horrifying is this now
everyone's gonna say can we just go back
to the monkey pictures yeah yeah
I just want the monkey picture
I'll pay a million for the monkey
picture yeah just not this yeah this is
horrifying dude horrifying yep
horrifying the implications of this are
I don't even know what but they're so
vast well I'm really glad that you know
open AI is a non-profit company now
uh it's for-profit unfortunately no it's
not probably there's for the good attack
it's called open AI right it's open it's
for no I'm really glad everyone punched
in all like their ideas and thoughts
about the world into this [__] Jarvis
system yeah now it's just gonna third
eye know so much about us yeah
everything we're thinking yeah
guys we're having a capped profit
yeah yeah okay so we're revising the
whole non-profit charitable thing and we
want to let you know that we are capping
about that all right all right
[Music]
uh we was camping about non-profit uh
economics of the open AI deal so here's
all your money
and then here's our bank account yeah
and this is about where it goes
more or less Microsoft bought
like a third of the company for 10
billion yeah at a 30 billion dollar
valuation
those [__] are building their
spaceship
they are leaving us yeah yeah yeah
they're gonna watch this [__] burn up
the probably they probably realize
like along the way yeah I bet that I bet
you that that's what it was they were
researching this [__] you know we're a
non-profit we're gonna make sure that
humanity is not and
the AI they're like hold it yeah it was
like the human race will die in 40 years
oh word
yeah
all right fellas we got to make as much
money as possible
[__] out of here we gotta live it up
yeah not time before I own a McLaren
dude
Sam Altman is just like a total [__] boy
I mean after after SBS I need to go to
11 every single night I don't know this
[__]
takes over this is like some bad Black
Mirror character yeah some girl dancing
on him so what do you do oh [__]
genius yeah
no actually I'm a [__] genius you
feeling really with AI yeah I've heard
of it yeah I made that
I made like 100 billion [__] dollars
last year yeah so what are you doing
here
all this shit's going to [__] man
my model told me we're all gonna [__]
die
so I'm just gonna do Coke and live it up
because we don't have much [__] time
left that's cool this guy's fun 100 of
the money to start first close Partners
FCP
huh
if it's all profits until the principal
is paid back after the FCP principal is
paid back 25 25 goes to employees and
FCP profit cap pay down is this current
oh the rest goes to Microsoft until it's
its investment is paid back once fully
paid down the rest of the profit goes to
11 strippers oh
it's crazy they just like listed it like
that yeah yeah Wild
at least they use their performance
names yeah you know they didn't use
their government names that's pretty in
theme with crypto you know
and and future Tech you know anonymity
and anonymous
yeah and not not a minute yeah
yeah dude AI scary